nous à tous merci de nous retrouver sur
public sénat les sénateurs ont donc voté
à leur tour hier soir à la taxe de 0 3%
pour les retraités imposables
l'objectif de cette taxe est d'amorcer
le financement de la réforme de la
dépendance
sans surprise les sénateurs communistes
ont voté contre cette disposition
depuis le début de l'examen du plfss le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
il réclamait en effet le retrait de cet
article 16 qualifiés de grande déception
pour des millions de salariés selon les
termes du sénateur communiste dominique
watrin je vous rappelle que les
sénateurs communistes conditionne le
vote de l'ensemble du préfet cesse au
retrait de cette disposition
on peut donc dire ce matin et bien que
le plfss risque d'être rejetée
probablement demain en fin de matinée
tout de suite donc direction l'hémicycle
pour revenir sur le vote de cette taxe
bonne matinée à tous la séance est
reprise
nous reprenons la suite de la discussion
du projet de loi adopté par l'assemblée
nationale de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2013 le gouvernement ayant
demandé la réserve des articles 14 à 15
terre et de l'article 20 et des
amendements tondon insérer de l'article
additionnel après l'article 20 j'appelle
en discussion l'article 16 sur l'article
16 g une demande de parole monsieur
dominique watrin
oui l'article 16 et pour notre groupe
comme pour des millions de salariés de
retraités une grande déception
au nom du financement de la perte
d'autonomie le gouvernement et sa
majorité présidentielle ont fait le
choix d'instaurer une taxe sur les
retraites qui s'apparente en réalité
l'idée défendue si même depuis des
années par alain vasselle d'instaurer
une cg alternative sur les retraités
personne ne conteste au groupe crc que
le vieillissement de la population
l'allongement de la durée de vie ainsi
que des modifications sociétales comme
l'explosion géographique des familles
génère des besoins nouveaux
mais la proposition formulée dans cet
article la première du gouvernement en
matière de dépendance consiste en une
ponction sur celles et ceux qui
pourraient avoir besoin prochainement
d'un accompagnement personnel lié à
leurs besoins d'autonomie
ce premier acte revient à considérer
c'est en tout cas comme ça que le
perçoivent nos concitoyens que les
personnes âgées sont d'abord et avant
tout un coup pour notre société avant
d'envisager de les taxer sans doute
aurait-il été plus sage et plus justes
d'intervenir rapidement pour réduire le
reste à charge qu'ils doivent aux colocs
leurs familles doivent supporter
lorsqu'elle sont accueillis en
établissements médico social on assiste
aujourd'hui une situation insupportable
d'un point de vue économique et humain
ou même une fois déduites les
différentes aides publiques à pas et de
logement dépenses fiscales
le reste à charge peut dans certains cas
être supérieur au revenu courant des
individus selon des études récentes
la participation mensuelle directe des
personnes dépendantes s'élève en moyenne
en établissement à 2200 euros en zone
rurale à 2900 en zone urbaine et 1400
euros à domicile alors que la retraite
moyenne en france est d'environ 1200
euros ne croyez-vous pas madame la
ministre que la priorité du gouvernement
en matière d'autonomie aurait dû être
porté plutôt sur cette question
j'avais d'ailleurs dénoncé cette
approche strictement financières et
comptables
lorsque nous immunise examinions il ya
quelques semaines à peine la proposition
de loi du sénateur gérard roche
l'article 1er modifier par voie
d'amendement revenait introduire le même
mécanisme au final que celui que nous
examinons aujourd'hui nous avions alors
dénoncé cette mesure avant lyon
souhaitait la repousse et ce pour
plusieurs raisons qui demeurent
aujourd'hui d'actualité notamment le
fait que cette mesure présente la nature
de la prise en charge de la perte
d'autonomie dans cet article 16 tous
nous incite à penser que la réforme de
la dépendance se fera en dehors de la
sécurité sociale c'est un point
important de nos interrogations le
financement est assuré
ici par une mesure fiscale et non par
les cotisations sociales produisent
cette taxe est orienté non vers la
sécurité sociale mais vers la scène et
ça les seules personnes mises à
contribution et en les personnes pouvant
bénéficier des aides financières et
humaines en matière d'autonomie enfin
vous avez clos ici avant qu'il ne soit
débuté le débat sur le champ de
l'autonomie j'espère que pour être
ouvert au plus vite
en tout cas nous ne pouvons nous
satisfaire aujourd'hui de cette
disposition dont groupe crc nous
défendons l'idée d'une grande réforme de
la dépendance dans laquelle les
départements auraient toute leur place
mais où les besoins seraient pris en
charge
d'abord par la sécurité sociale sécurité
sociale réformer la cns a seraient
réintégrés dans une sous branches
dépendance qu'il faudrait constituer et
dans laquelle la participation des
usagers des citoyens ce pourrait être
renforcée légitimes y est notamment par
la réintroduction d'élections une
réforme de la perte d'autonomie
qui partirait aussi des besoins réels de
nos concitoyens ce qui nous incite
aujourd'hui à défendre l'idée que la
construction de ce droit nouveau doit
correspondre aux attentes des personnes
vieillissantes comme des personnes en
situation de handicap
cela suppose assure un financement
solidaire est conforme à l'esprit du
conseil national de la résistance et sur
cette question le groupe crc se
distingue effectivement c'est un constat
de tous les autres groupes
parlementaires faire payer les retraités
au motif qu'il bénéficierait de ce droit
c'est en réalité s'inscrire clairement
dans une logique assurantielle énonce se
disent solidaires
l'adoption de cet article pour alors
conduire à ce que demain non seulement
l'on supprime leur prise en charge des
ald est à 100% mais qu'on les surtaxes
aux maladies qu au motif que leur les
maladies coûterait plus cher la sécurité
se soient sociales voilà on pourrait
nous conduire le raisonnement qui sert
de postulats à cet article ce qui est
sans doute le fruit d'un renoncement
nous n'avons eu de cesse d'exhorter
votre gouvernement à revenir sur cette
mesure afin notamment que puisse
s'engager une concertation véritable à
ce sujet nous n'avons pas eu de réponse
nous proposerons un amendement donc de
substitution à certains tics le 16
et si malheureusement celui ci ne devait
pas être adoptés n'était pas soutenu par
le gouvernement qui s'engagerait alors à
renoncer à cette taxe sauf nous serions
contraints de voter contre cet article
merci chers collègues
alors nous avons quatre amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion excusez
moi excusez moi madame lepage vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre shah collet l'article
16 se justifie aisément par l'équité en
effet d'une part l'une des propositions
toujours mis en avant pour le
financement d'une meilleure prise en
charge de la dépendance et
l'élargissement de l'assiette de la
contribution de solidarité pour
l'autonomie
d'autre part au regard de l'amélioration
des niveaux de vie des retraités
il importe conformément à la volonté de
la majorité de redressement dans la
justice de nos finances de redéfinir
les termes de la solidarité temps entre
les générations comme au sein des
générations la pertinence de cette
disposition ne fait donc aucun doute
pour ce qui concerne spécifiquement les
salariés retraités résidant fiscalement
à l'étranger hors pays de l'espace
économique européen
mais dépendant d'un régime français
d'assurance maladie il bénéficie d'un
traitement spécifique puisqu'il ne sont
redevables ni de la csg ni la crds mais
qu'ils s'acquittent d'une cotisation de
3,2 pour cent sur le retraite de base et
de 4,2 pour cent sur leur retraite
complémentaire
les pensions de retraite du régime
général des personnes fiscalement
domiciliées en france étant elles
soumises à la csg un taux de 6,6 pour
cent ainsi qu'à la crds au taux de 0,5
pour cent
le remboursement des soins dispensés à
l'étranger est subordonné à l'adhésion à
la caisse des français de l'étranger
dont la cotisation s'élève à 4 % du
montant des pensions
ce remboursement est temps calculé sur
la base des frais réels les coûts locaux
dans la limite des tarifs appliqués en
métropole
le ticket modérateur étant bien sûr à la
charge de l'assuré une demande
récurrente des retraités résidents
fiscaux à l'étranger et dépendant d'un
régime français d'assurance maladie et
la possibilité d'une prise en charge de
soins dispensés à l'étranger par le
régime général dans la limite bien sûr
des tarifs appliqués en france mais la
situation de la caisse de sécurité
sociale du régime général ne le permet
bien évidemment pas mais madame la
ministre vous avez plusieurs fois
souligné que lors de la présentation de
ce budget de la sécurité sociale qu'il
était un budget de justice je
souhaiterais donc avoir confirmation que
les pensions des retraités résidant
fiscalement à l'étranger exonérés de la
csg et de la crds sont également comme
leurs compatriotes vivant en france
exonérée de la nouvelle contribution
additionnelle
de solidarité pour l'autonomie collègue
madame ministre
en effet monsieur watrin nous avons
écouté je crois je n'avais pas eu ce
privilège puisque vous étiez en séance
tout à l'heure
le président de la république qui nous a
rappelé d'une part à la justice et
d'autre part à la clarté elle avait il
des monsieur le sénateur 20 trains
peut-on dire que cette mesure n'est pas
juste
nous en avons exagéré les retraités non
imposables non imposables à l'impôt sur
le revenu qu'à la taxe d'habitation
c'est à dire les deux premières tranches
de la cg et le montant de cette
cotisation additionnelle exceptionnel
est de 4 euros pour la le taux la
retraite de base de ce caractère
imposable de 1320 euros
est ce que l'on peut dire que c'est
vraiment un impôt déloyale ou de
cotisations déloyale d'autre part je
vous ai entendu précédemment nous dire
qu'il fallait tenir compte en priorité
des besoins des ag qui s'engagent dans
ce long parcours et heureusement qui est
aujourd'hui long grâce à l'allongement
de la vie de l'appeler vente ul perte
d'autonomie
en tout cas de l'avancée en âge mais les
besoins de ces ag nous les connaissons
est ce que la droite pendant cinq ans
qui nous a fait miroiter cette réforme
ne les a pas dégagé en grande partie
mais soyez sûr d'autre part que nous
continuons d'y travailler d'auditionner
de concerter nous les connaissons et
vous avez eu tout à fait raison de
parler du reste à charge qui plombe
nombre de familles mais
savons que nous allons essayer
d'améliorer concrètement quotidiennement
la situation de ces français et de la
famille donc ses besoins nous les
connaissons donc je vous engage la
vraiment une démarche de vérité de
clarté il est normal que tous
contribuent aujourd'hui au financement
de cette perte d'autonomie et cette
cotisation additionnelle exceptionnelle
les deux mots sont justes vous le savez
vaut pour va contribuer dès l'année
prochaine à ce financement
et je crois qu en toute loyauté en toute
clarté
on ne peut pas dire qu'elle soit injuste
merci madame la ministre vous avez la
parole
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs et quelques
mots de plus par rapport à ce que vient
d'indiquer ma collègue michèle delaunay
je voudrais au faut reprendre ce que je
vous ai dit hier monsieur le sénateur
watrin et c'est vrai que c'est un débat
que nous avons engagé il y a maintenant
quelques semaines et vous avez raison de
dire que nous avons eu l'occasion de
nous rencontrer vous avez rencontré le
gouvernement nous nous sommes vus nous
avons échangé et je sais à quel point
cet article 16 est pour vous un enjeu
important dans le cadre de ce projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale je sais que cela fait partie
pour vous même et votre groupe
des dispositions qui sont les plus
sensibles
je voudrais néanmoins et très rapidement
puisque nous avons eu l'occasion
d'échanger déjà sur ce point vous dire
que le gouvernement a été attentif à
votre préoccupation je ne peux pas vous
laisser dire que nous ne vous avons
apporté aucune réponse
notre réponse est une réponse qui ne
vous satisfait pas et qui n'entre pas
dans la perspective qui est la vôtre
mais nous vous avons indiqué un certain
nombre d'éléments et que j'ai rappelé
hier je veux très rapidement revenir sur
ce que je vous ai dit d'abord l'enjeu
bien de mettre en place le financement
d'une réforme de l'accompagnement de la
perte d'autonomie qui a été oublié au
cours des dernières années et de faire
en sorte que ce financement repose non
pas sur l'assurance privée mais sur la
solidarité nationale dès lors que l'on
parle de solidarité nationale il est
nécessaire que le financement lui même
repose sur nous et présente un caractère
de solidarité faut-il au nom de la
solidarité c'est mon deuxième point
exclure les retraités une partie des
retraités nous avons eu l'occasion
d'évoquer ce point longuement hier une
partie de retraités les retraités
imposables
je voulais dit nous pensons que ça n'est
pas souhaitable et c'est là sans doute
qu'il y a une différence d'appréciation
entre nous parce que j'ai bien vu que
vous alliez présenté un amendement
proposant de substituer d'autres
ressources aux ressources qui sont
appelés dans le cadre de cette
cotisation de solidarité spécifique
l'enjeu est financier assurément mais
l'enjeu n'est pas uniquement financier
il est de s'interroger sur la manière
dont nous concevons dans l'avenir le
financement de notre protection sociale
je ne serai pas longue je les développer
largement et longuement hier soir je
vous ai indiqué que si nous voulons que
notre modèle de protection sociale
conserve sa force conserve sa légitimité
notamment au regard des jeunes
générations dans les années à venir nous
avions besoin que chacune et chacun en
particulier dans les générations
aujourd'hui retraité apporte sa
contribution si non que nous le voulions
ou pas nous prenons le risque de voir
s'immiscer une forme de doute de
d'interrogation des plus jeunes
vis-à-vis de leurs les générations de
leurs parents ou de leurs grands parents
avec l'idée au fond que certains
seraient exonérés de la contribution à
l'avenir de notre protection sociale si
nous voulons non seulement
conserver mais ce qui est l'ambition du
gouvernement élargir les droits sociaux
dans notre pays dans les années à venir
alors nous avons le devoir d'être
extrêmement attentif à ce que soit
accepté les mesures de financement et
les mesures de contribution de me
demander à l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est
aussi une des raisons pour lesquelles au
delà des enjeux financiers au delà du ca
de la simple volonté d'engager le
financement de la perte d'autonomie
nous avons cette recherche d'équité
entre les générations
l'avenir de la protection sociale il
passe par un financement solidaire mais
aussi un financement qui fait appel à
l'ensemble des générations je voudrais
par ailleurs je terminerai par la
répondre à un point que vous avez
évoquées qui était le fait que nous
envisagerions le financement de la perte
d'autonomie dans un cadre extérieur à la
sécurité sociale et dans la mesure où
nous mettions en place une cotisation
qui était une cotisation fiscale et non
pas une cotisation enfin donc un impôt
disons et non pas une cotisation
justement au sens de la sécurité sociale
je veux vous dire monsieur le sénateur
que aujourd'hui nous n'avons pris aucune
décision concernant le mode de
financement et la nature des
contributions qui seront appelés pour
permettre l'élargissement de notre
politique d'accompagnement de la perte
d'autonomie mais il me semble que le
plus important c'est que le financement
de cette nouvelle prestation ou de cette
nouvelle politique repose sur les
principes de la protection sociale
savoir si ce sera une branche à
l'intérieur de la sécurité sociale est
au fond aujourd'hui assez secondaire par
rapport à la question de savoir quels
sont les principes qui fondent la
politique est au fond je le dis très
simplement il y a quelques années nous
nous sommes interrogés
ou à l'opposition de l'époque sur la
mise en place de la caisse nationale de
la solidarité aujourd'hui nous
constatons que cette caisse travaille
bien en relation avec les conseils
généraux et nous savons que l'un des
éléments essentiels pour le succès de la
politique à venir sera qu'elles soient
déterminées en étroite coopération entre
le gouvernement d'un côté les conseils
généraux les collectivités territoriales
donc les conseils généraux de l'autre et
cela me paraît et nous paraît plus
important que de savoir quel est le lieu
d'élaboration ou d'inscription de la
politique dès lors que les principes
fondamentaux de la protection sociale
c'est-à-dire des principes de solidarité
qui met à contribution les revenus de
chacun en fonction de leur niveau et
apporte des garanties en fonction des
besoins
dès lors que ces principes seraient
respectés je voudrais madame lepage vous
dire madame la sénatrice vous dire
simplement que il y à un principe de
résidence pour ce qui est de la
contribution et à partir de là dès lors
qu'il ya la résidence est à l'étranger
la pension sera exonérée de la
contribution qui est demandé mais dès
lors que ces retraités reviendrait
s'installer dans notre pays il serait à
l'évidence mis à contribution dans les
mêmes conditions que les résidents en
france
merci madame la ministre nous avons
quatre amendements qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 68 et présenté par
madame cohen
oui le but de cet amendement est simple
suite à ce que vient de dire dominique
watrin c'est remplacer la taxe sur les
retraites que nous trouvons vous l'avez
compris profondément injuste socialement
et politiquement par une recette qui
vise au contraire à tirer de notre point
de vue la société vers le haut et qui
s'appuie sur un certain nombre
d'engagements de votre gouvernement en
la matière nous proposons en effet de
supprimer les exonérations des
contributions sociales pour les
employeurs qui ne respectent pas
l'égalité professionnelle
j'ai déjà évoqué ici les chiffres des
chiffres éloquents notamment lors de
l'examen de la ppl de notre collègue
claire-lise campion
je me permet de les porter à nouveau à
votre connaissance en tout cas de vous
les rappeler
une étude de l'insee de 2008 et portant
sur les salaires versés en 2007 indique
en effet que la masse totale des
salaires versés en direction des
salariés du secteur privé atteint la
somme de 460 milliards 2 millions
d'euros sur l'année la part de masses
salariales non versées en raison des
inégalités salariales représentent quant
à elles 124 milliards d'euros ce sont
donc 124 milliards d'euros par an qui ne
sont pas versées aux femmes en raison
des inégalités salariales dont elles
sont victimes
par ailleurs toujours selon cette étude
la sécurité sociale perd plus de 52
milliards d'euros de cotisations en
raison donc de ces inégalités salariales
entre les femmes et les hommes
à elle seule la résolution de ces
inégalités permettrait de réduire de
façon considérable déficits cumulés de
la sécurité sociale qu'il s'élève vous
le savez à 100 milliards
cet amendement présente donc un double
avantage non seulement il évite une taxe
injuste envers des retraités dont on
connaît très bien les difficultés
financières mais de plus car cette
mesure permet enfin l'égalité
professionnelle de passer des bonnes
intentions une réalité effective du fait
de contraintes mises en place par le
législateur
j'ajoute que l'an dernier nous avions
déposé un amendement similaire et qu'il
avait été adopté par notre assemblée
je ne vois aucun délai
aujourd'hui qui pourrait contredire ce
que nous avons donc voté hier et donc
j'espère que nous ferons ensemble de
même je vous remercie
merci chers collègues l'amendement 345
rectifier et présentée par monsieur
desessard oui donc pour parce que madame
la ministre a défini les contours d'une
intervention que je partage tout d'abord
je crois que j'ai terminé hier soir mon
intervention en dg en disant qu'il
fallait réfléchir au nouveau pacte
social
ce que mes amis du crc insiste sur le la
solidarité sociale et je pense que sur
ses bancs nous y sommes favorables pour
maintenant est ce que comme on peut la
construire
est ce que oui non parce c'est de façon
catégorielles que nous la présenter
madame cohen et met donc lorsque pas une
catégorie mais enfin à chaque fois on
pose quand même le problème par
catégorie il faut quand même réfléchir
oui bon mais soyez pas jaloux
mais je parlais avec vous non puisque
j'ai parlé vous faire plaisir puisque
j'ai parlé du transfert
la baisse des cotisations sociales
la question qui est posée par exemple
est ce que c'est normal que l'assurance
chômage
c'était normal à une époque l'assurance
chômage soit payée par les personnes qui
travaillaient qui mettait de côté et
caves et n'assurant ce là ce qu'ils
perdent l emploi mais est ce que c'est
normal si on prend le problème au niveau
de la société que ça se soit les
entreprises de main d'oeuvre qui paie
l'assurance chômage pour les entreprises
qui ont licencié parce qu'elles ont mis
en place des robots non on voit très
bien qu'il ya des choses nouvelles à
fléchir le problème de la santé c'est
plus simplement pas liés aux accidents
de la vie c'est maintenant la santé
c'est dans tous les domaines c'est au
quotidien c'est comment produits comment
se nourrit
comment quelles sont les relations avec
eux les dans l'entreprise c'est une
nouvelle définition de la centif vous
posez et pour les retraites
est-ce que nous sommes toujours dans un
système de salaire différé
est ce qu'on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui et
bien les retraites c'est simplement
l'accumulation des deux poings on a pu
faire tout au long de sa vie ou
d'annuités puisque ça revient au même
d'ailleurs le terme de retraites par
répartition laisse poser pas mal dans
big beat et on al impression qu on
répartit les retraites en réalité on
calcule les retraites en fonction du
salaire on a accumulé tout au long d'une
vie
je ne sais pas si c'est ça la
répartition simplement c'est un système
dit par répartition d'une génération sur
l'autre mais pas de solidarité pour ben
dis donc à partir du moment qu'on
considère que ça c'est toutes ces
questions là doivent être posées et je
pense qu'on a quatre ou cinq ans
peut-être plus nous la gauche pour
réfléchir à un nouveau pacte social pour
en venir à l'amendement puisque vaut
bien que je termine pour en revenir à
l'amendement
cela a été dit les petites retraites ne
sont pas touchés et
vous avez posé problème de la dépendance
le point de dépendance et bien au-delà
de la cotisation qu'on va demander là ça
pose bien d'autres problèmes
l'indépendance je ne sais pas mais nous
attendons les propositions du
gouvernement comment on va pouvoir la
finance c'est autre chose mais en tout
cas ce n'est pas lié au fait de la
cotisation qui est demandé aujourd'hui
donc nous nous sommes favorable à cet
amendement dans ce sens qui doit y aura
une solidarité entre l'ensemble les
actifs aujourd'hui mais monsieur
présence du raccourci se raccourcit les
actifs aujourd'hui pour en bois yens ou
un niveau eux ont un pouvoir d'achat qui
équivalent aux retraités en moyenne bien
entendu et comme en touche pas aux
petites retraites
on peut dire que l'effort il est partagé
et pour montrer qu'effectivement c'est
un effort qui doit être solidaire nous
présentons un amendement sur la
progressivité des cotisations merci
chers collègues nous enchaînons sur
l'amendement 217 rectifié qui est
présentée par monsieur roche sur
président mesdames les ministres mes
chers collègues je vais essayer d'être
plus bref parce que leur avance le 25
octobre dernier
notre assemblée a adopté la proposition
de loi que j'avais l'honneur représenté
avec le groupe udc pour l'élargissement
de la journée sur les vérités et la
compensation de la pao département
concernant les pensions de retraite
le dip le dispositif que nous proposions
s'apparente à la contribution que crée
l'article 16 la casa un prélèvement de 0
3 % des patients dont sont exonérés
on en donne acte les petites retraites
le problème que nous pose l'article 16
c'est l'affectation sur prélèvement qui
ne gênera en rien compensé la pao
département initialement le projet de
loi prévoit que le produit de cette taxe
soit fléchés sur le financement de la
fsv après passage à l'assemblée
nationale il est prévu que la casa soit
fléchi à 95 95 % sur la section 2
de la ceni ça c'est à dire à la
compensation de l'apa pour le
département
mais dans le même temps la fraction cg
affectés à cette section sera réorientée
à due concurrence à due concurrence sur
le fcv si bien que les départements
auront la même ressource de compensation
en 2013 après 2013 la casa financera la
future réforme de la dépendance dans une
section nouvelles qui sera créée au
niveau du cn est sain mais les
départements qui supportent à 70%
la dépense de l'apa ne peuvent un an de
plus se satisfaire d'un précision
jusqu'à 2014 et même au delà
cette affectation est donc pour nous
très très insatisfaisante lirai pas il
est absurde pompa de l'esa me direz il
est incompréhensible d'affecter une
ressource au financement d'une réforme
future dont nos c'est derrière encore
rien alors que le financement des
dispositifs existants n'est pas assurée
dans la droite ligne la proposition
adoptée par le sénat
notre banc demain affecte donc de
manière pérenne lakasa à la compensation
de lapin par ailleurs pour l'année 2013
uniquement et afin que le fsv soit
équilibré et comprenant bien les soucis
du gouvernement nous sommes prêts a
souvent manqué notre amendement ou
proposons au gouvernement de le faire
lui-même pour que la moitié de la casa
ou la faction cg correspondante abonde
le fsv à charge pour le gouvernement
d'équilibrer ce fameux fsv l'année
suivante je précise que pour nous chers
collègues
cet amendement est un amendement crée et
il se pourrait bien que le sort de ce
plfss pour 2013 ce jour sur cet article
16 merci chers collègues
enfin l'amendement 389 et présentée par
monsieur le rapporteur général au nom de
la commission des affaires sociales
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres d'amendements que je vous
propose répondent en partie aux attentes
qui viennent d'être exclu par monsieur
roche mais surtout aux attentes qui sont
très largement partagé ici au sénat
concernant le financement de l'apa tout
en respectant les modalités
d'affectation de la contribution prévue
par le gouvernement pour 2013
dans la version initiale du plfss
le produit de la casa doit s'élever à
350 millions d'euros en 2013 pour un
taux de 0 15%
l'assemblée nationale a reporté l'entrée
en vigueur de la casa au 1er avril 2013
tout en portant son taux à 0 3%
dès l'année prochaine en outre
l'assiette de la contribution a été
réduite au sort retraités assujettis au
taux de csg de droit commun
l'ensemble de ces modifications fait
passer le rendement de la casa de 350 à
450 millions d'euros en 2013
l'article 16 prévoyait en outre à titre
exceptionnel que la casa soit
intégralement versés au fsv en 2013 par
un mécanisme complexe
l'assemblée nationale a prévu d'affecter
entièrement en section 2 c'est le
financement ne va pas et 4 ce sont les
actions innovantes du budget de la cns a
le produit de la casa tout en diminuant
indus concurrence la part de csg
affectés à ces sections pour la
rediriger vers le fsv l'opération est
donc neutre pour ce dernier mais
également pour lacérer nsa qui est de
bénéfices ira d'aucune augmentation de
ses recettes en 2013
il est cependant possible mais
impossible tout en préservant les
équilibres initiale du plfss de ne
reverser que 350 millions d'euros au fsv
en 2013 soit le montant prévu
initialement par le gouvernement tout en
allouant à la scène et ça les 100
millions d'euros supplémentaires issus
du vote de l'assemblée nationale
95 % de cette recette de 100 millions
d'euros contribuerait au financement de
l'apa 5% à celui d'action innovant
tel est donc l'objet
du présent amendement dans son grand 2
qui apporte en outre une amélioration
rédactionnel dans son ventre
je voudrais insister mesdames les
ministres sur le fait suivant j'ai bien
le sentiment parce que l'amendement
d'apporter du désordre dans le schéma
que vous aviez imaginé de construction
du père fss mais je voudrais vraiment
insister sur le point suivant
l'enjeu c'est moins la question de
l'équilibré des budgets départementaux
l'an prochain même si c'est important et
je suis aussi président de conseil
général
l'enjeu c'est la capacité de financer
l'apa en 2013
alors il y a ici une opportunité j'ai
bien écouté le président de la
république
j'ai bien entendu l'engagement qui a été
pris par le président d'engager en 2013
des négociations qui permettront de
pérenniser un financement en 2014
c'est la raison pour laquelle mon
amendement ne porte que sur l'année 2013
j'ai bien entendu également l'engagement
la création d'un fonds d'intervention
exceptionnels à hauteur de 170 millions
d'euros
si nous pouvions mettre en pratique
l'amendement que je vous propose ce
serait 100 millions supplémentaires qui
viendraient contribuer au financement de
l'apa en 2013 et qui faciliterait
largement donc ce financement
merci monsieur rapporteur général
est ce que nous pouvons en chesnais sur
l'avis de la commission sur les autres
amendements mot sur la porte au général
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres donc un moment numéro 68 qui a
été présentée par laurence cohen je ne
trompe pas donc ces amendements
nous sommes là au coeur du sujet a pour
objet de réécrire totalement l'article
16 afin de remplacer la casa par la
suppression des exonérations de
cotisations sociales pour les
entreprises qui ne respectent pas leurs
obligations de négociations sur les
objectifs d'égalité professionnelle
entre les hommes et les femmes
je comprends et nous comprenons le souci
de vouloir remédier aux inégalités
salariales entre les hommes et les
femmes mais il me ne me semble pas
pertinent
ah c'est un sens de vouloir supprimer
l'article 16
vous soulignez que le prélèvement qui
pèsera sur les retraités est injuste il
déjà été apporté beaucoup d'éléments de
réponse dont par mesdames les ministres
je voudrais rappeler à mon tour que le
dispositif tel qu'il a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale permet d'exclure
les pensions les plus modestes puisque
44% des retraités seront exonérés du
paiement de la casa en outre il ne
s'agit pas de créer une taxe qui serait
supportée uniquement par le retraité
mais d'étendre l'assiette de la casa qui
ne pèsent jusqu'à présent que sur les
travailleurs salariés et dans une
moindre mesure sur les revenus du
patrimoine et les produits de placement
j insiste par ailleurs sur le fait que
le produit de la casa sera dès 1900 dès
2014 pardon entièrement affectés au
financement de la future réforme de la
dépendance dont les retraités seront les
premiers bénéficiaires
il s'agit d'une réforme essentielle qui
a été trop longtemps retardée cela a
déjà été dit et avec insistance je
soutiens donc pleinement la volonté du
gouvernement de s'engager dès à présent
dans cette voie par le biais de ses
articles et la commission des affaires
sociales dont demande le retrait ou
émettra à défaut un avis défavorable à
l'amendement qui a été
pris sous le numéro 68 concernant
l'amendement numéro 340,5 donc ces
amendements visent à rendre la casa
progressive alors la logique qui la
sous-tend est compréhensible qui le
sous-tend pardon l'amendement est
compréhensible mais il me semble que
compte tenu du taux très faibles la
contribution 0 3% et du nombre déjà
important de retraités qui en seront
exonérés je rappelle 44% rendre la casa
progressif contribuerez surtout à
alourdir et complexifier le dispositif
la commission des affaires sociales
demande de retrait de cet amendement où
il mettra également à défaut donc un
avis défavorable et j'en viens à
l'amendement donc numéro 10 est présenté
par l'ue des é u s'est donc présentée
par monsieur roche ne trompe pas
toujours à mes amendements
c'est un moment a pour objet de revoir
totalement les modalités d'affectation
du produit de la casa celui ci ne
seraient plus mises en réserve au sein
d'une nouvelle section du budget de la
cn et ça mais affectée aux sections 2 et
4 c'est à dire pour 95 % au financement
de l'apa pour 5 % à celui d'actions
innovantes et de formation en août le
dispositif transitoire prévue pour 2013
qui vise à affecter la recette au fsv
seraient supprimés alors je comprends
bien le souci de préserver les finances
des départements et ce faisant leur
capacité à continuer de verser la pâte
dans les conditions satisfaisantes
cette préoccupation est partagée par la
plupart des élus dans cet hémicycle
quelle que soit leur sensibilité
politique je note également qu'il existe
un consensus relativement large au sein
de notre haute assemblée pour élargir
l'assiette de la csa des revenus
salariaux vers les pensions de retraites
à l'exception des plus modestes d'entre
elles et débattent qui ont accompagné
l'examen de votre position sur auch de
loi le 25 octobre dernier ont montré
tout cela nous divergeons cependant
concernant l'affectation du produit
la casa en effet il ne me semble pas
pertinent de la dédier dans sa quasi
totalité au financement de l'apa et ce
pour trois raisons
en premier lieu parce que cela
reviendrait à présenter en grande partie
le débat que nous aurons en 2014
au moment de l'examen du texte relatif à
la prise en charge de la dépendance et
qui permettra j'en suis convaincu de
trouver un mode de partage des charges
plus équitable entre l'état et les
départements dans l'accompagnement de
nos aînés en deuxième lieu parce que
depuis le lundi 22 octobre et la
rencontre du président de la république
avec des représentants des conseils
généraux nous avons l'assurance qu'un
fonds d'urgence de 170 millions d'euros
va être mis en place en 2013 au profit
des départements les plus fragiles et
enfin surtout parce que l'amendement
priverait s'il était adopté
le fsv des 350 millions d'euros que le
gouvernement a prévu de lui affecter en
2013 montant portée à 450 millions
d'euros par l'assemblée nationale
d'amendements rompre et donc les
équilibres établis par le plfss sans
proposer de ressources de substitution
pour le fsv ces différents éléments ont
conduit la commission des affaires
sociales à émettre un avis défavorable a
donc l'amendement 217
merci monsieur vente en général madame
la ministre quel est l'avis de la
commission et du gouvernement
répondre sur une portion d'un fin sur
une part des amendements qui viennent d
être présenté une fois encore en en
appelant aux paroles du président de la
république cet après midi c'est à dire
d'une part le sens de la responsabilité
à chaque peinte d'un traction à chaque
engagements que nous prenons et
deuxièmement heures cet engagement de
vérité de lisibilité auquel il nous a
appelés
monsieur le sénateur proche nous avons
été unis pendant plusieurs heures dans
des débats extrêmement productif est
intéressant parce qu'il était important
que nous avancions et nous nous
connaissions davantage que nous
partagions chacun nos difficultés
à propos de votre proposition de loi
dans la discussion générale je vous ai
appelé à ne pas opposer le financement
de l'apa au financement de
l'accompagnement de la perte d'autonomie
parce que derrière plein et l'autre il y
a en effet le l'enjeu considérable de
l'avancée en âge et de cette perte
d'autonomie que nous vous look l envers
laquelle nous voulons que la république
soit plus présente et plus solidaire le
président de la république et l'ensemble
du gouvernement ont parfaitement entendu
les demandes les besoins les difficultés
des départements et je crois que le
président de la république et le
gouvernement entend donner la preuve en
débloquant un fonds d'urgence très
importante 170 millions d'euros mais
aussi en prenant l'engagement de
travailler la main dans la main pour la
réforme de la perte d'autonomie sous la
forme d'un groupe de travail et
d'assurer une contribution pérenne pour
le financement de l'apa alors maintenant
nous sommes devant un enjeu de
lisibilité et de compréhension de vérité
vis-à-vis de tous les français
la tuyauterie que j'appellerais d'un
tuyau tring bat est déjà complexe de
comprendre qu'une que la location via
sur la cn et ça repart et cetera mais
elle est encore compréhensible si nous
la perturbe on si nous rendons 95% dans
une direction dans une autre plus
personne n'y comprendra rien et notre
message sera d'autant plus complexe
donc je crois qu en toute loyauté en
toute compréhension ainsi proc des
difficultés de chacun et des ambitions
de chacun qui sont les mêmes c'est à
dire d'être présent pour accompagner ce
défi considérable qui est l'avancée en
âge et la perte de demis où nous devons
maintenant à un effort de simplicité de
loyauté et de promesses de bien
travailler ensemble c'est pour ça que
pour ma part je donne un avis
défavorable aux amendements ou deux
derniers amendements qui ont été
proposées m'adapte ou rehn s'exprimant
sur l'ensemble tulle des hameaux madame
la ministre alors même si vous pouvez
m'écrire un tout petit peu sur eux les
précisément sur l'amendement numéro 68
qui a été présenté par madame cohen je
voudrais indiquer que je comprends et je
partage la préoccupation de vous même
madame la sénatrice et de votre groupe
de faire en sorte que par l'instauration
de pénalités puisse être réalisé des
avancées en matière d'égalité
professionnelle hommes/femmes je ne suis
néanmoins pas certaine que cet objectif
est sa place ou trouve sa place dans ce
texte
et je vous avoue que je ne suis pas
certaine de lire un lien ou de voir un
lien très compréhensible et identifiées
entre la volonté d'un côté de faire
progresser l'égalité hommes femmes et de
l'autre pour autant que celle ci
progresse à travers le type de pénalités
que vous proposez mais je n'ouvre pas ce
débat là et puis d'autre part le
financement de
la perte de politique de perte
d'autonomie pour cette première raison
je dois avouer que je ne suis pas
convaincu par la proposition que vous
faites la deuxième chose sur laquelle je
voudrais insister c'est que le mécanisme
que vous proposez qui encore une fois me
paraît justifié est aujourd'hui inscrit
à l'ordre du jour des négociations sur
le la la la sécurisation des parcours
professionnels négociations qui résulte
de la grande conférence sociale du mois
de juillet dernier et qui nous
l'espérons aboutira dans les prochaines
semaines c'est un des éléments sur
lesquels les partenaires sociaux
eux-mêmes souhaite pouvoir s'exprimer il
ne me semble donc pas justifié de
comment dire couper court à cette
négociation à l'occasion de ce texte de
loi enfin aucun élément ne permet
d'apprécier le montant des ressources
qui résulterait de votre amendement au
regard des ressources qui ont été
indiquées dans le texte de loi est donc
pour ces trois raisons
je suis au regret d'apporter un avis
défavorable à votre amendement à
monsieur des essarts pour l'amendement
numéro 3 145 je voudrais indiquer que là
encore je partage l'idée que nous
devrions sans doute réfléchir à une plus
grande progressivité de la contribution
est pas simplement proportionnalité
néanmoins vous n'êtes pas monsieur le
sénateur sans ignorer que c'est un
bouleversement significatif de notre
organisation fiscale bouleversement tel
d'ailleurs que je ne suis pas certaine
qu'il serait considérée comme
constitutionnel puisque des personnes
disposant de revenus différents revenus
du capital par exemple ou autres types
de revenus seraient taxés au titre de
cette cotisation de façon identique
alors que le conseil constitutionnel a
eu l'occasion d'exprimer la nécessité de
prendre en compte l'intégralité des
revenus dès lors que l'on voulait y
instaurer une vision une fiscalité
progressive et donc pour cette raison
principale alors même que notre texte
prévoit déjà une différence entre les
retraités 1
osa bhl et les autres c'est à dire les
petits revenus et des autres jeux
j'apporte un avis défavorable au nom du
gouvernement à votre amendement enfin
pour les amendements pour l'amendement
numéro 2 217
je ne reviens pas sur ce qui a été dit
par madame delaunay nous apportons un
avis défavorable je voudrais indiquer
l'importance de du financement des
conseils généraux pour le gouvernement
je ne reviens pas sur ce qu'a dit
monsieur le rapporteur général et que
vous savez le gouvernement travaille
avec les conseils généraux pour faire en
sorte que soient sécurisés ce
financement
mais c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle
j'apporte je souhaiterais que
l'amendement numéro 3 189 présenté par
la commission puisse être retirée sinon
je devrais lui donner un avis
défavorable en effet je comprends bien
que la commission a essayé de trouver
une un équilibre enfin le rapporteur a
été trouvé un équilibre entre les
contraintes les différentes contraintes
qui existent néanmoins vous avez vous
même souligné la nécessité d'apporter
des financements au fonds de solidarité
vieillesse qui est gravement
déficitaires et dont nous devons assurer
progressivement l'équilibré donc si vous
ne retirez riez pas votre amendement au
nom du gouvernement et avec regret je
devrais lui apporter un avis défavorable
merci madame la ministre alors nous
sommes sur l'amendement 68ème des
demandes d'explications de vote
je n'en ai pas que ceux qui souhaitent
adopter vais bien levé la main merci que
ceux qui sont contre veuille bien levé
la main l'amendement n'est pas adopté
j'en arrive en l'amendant 345 rectifié
j'ai une demande d'explications de vote
de monsieur desessard
monsieur le président je serais vrai
parce que j'ai eu le sentiment d' abuser
un petit peu tout à l'heure donc je vais
te tout est dans la modestie et j'ai été
sensible aux propos du rapporteur de man
amani ce qu'ils ont dit qu'ils ont bien
compris le sens de mon amendement qui
était la progressivité donc de tenir
compte des revenus 1 et donc j'étais
sensible au fait que mon amendement été
compris et de mon côté je suis sensible
à votre argument de la complexité qu'il
y aurait à l'installer c'est
effectivement un système complexe
nouveau et qui pose d'autres problèmes
que simplement l'application à 7 à ce
projet de loi en conséquence je vais
vous vous écoutez est retiré merci chers
collègues
il est donc retiré nous en arrivons à
l'amendement 217 rectifié explications
de vote le ccv rit oui à propos de cet
amendement permettez moi monsieur le
président de repréciser un peu les
enjeux qui concernent cette dépendance
notamment pour les départements on a
déjà eu l'occasion de l'exprimer
hier soir l'exprimé avec madame le mini
la ministre des personnes âgées
également l exprimer devant le président
de la république
mais l'enjeu est quand même lourd pour
compenser la pas à 50% pour les
départements il manque chaque année un
milliard d'euros 1 milliard d'euros là
on parle d'une compensation qui serait
certes intéressantes d'environ 100
millions d'euros
je crois que les enjeux sont
complètement différents et véritablement
faut trouver faut trouver une solution
pour les départements ain orma je
partage le point de vue de madame la
ministre j'écoute le président de la
république nous a fait l'honneur en tant
que présidents de conseils généraux de
nous recevoir de façon très très très
constructive dans un certain nombre de
domaines et j'ai bien retenu la
proposition notamment de monsieur le
premier ministre qui nous disaient être
regardés avec vigilance
un certain nombre d'amendements qui
permettrait au département de s'en tirer
rappelez vous son expression il a dit si
rien n'est fait les
département sont morts donc je prends à
la lettre l'expression du président de
la république pour dire que l'engagement
d'un financement en 2014 de la
dépendance engagements qu'il a pris
devant les présidents de conseils
généraux est bien loin et qu'il faut
attendre encore 2014 et compte tenu de
l'ensemble des prestations de solidarité
qui ne sont pas suffisamment compensé ce
sont par an 6 milliard d'euros qui
manque au niveau des départements et il
n'arrive plus à équilibrer leur budget
d'où derrière l'absence de croissance et
président de la république et celui qui
réclame la croissance à juste titre il a
fait la différence pendant l'élection
avec ce problème de croissance et
préoccupations de croissance par rapport
à d'autres donc il est essentiel de
permettre au département d'être des
leviers de croissance
ils en vivent dans un certain nombre de
domaines de la survie du pays
alors permettez moi de vous dire qu'on
est particulièrement parfois estomaqué
par rapport aux propositions qui nous
sont faites
nous avions un débat hier soir sur la
pâte ossification la médicalisation des
crédits que vous accordez ils sont pas
consommés ils vont servir à les
alimenter l'assurance maladie alors que
ce sont des 'credit cns à qui au départ
étaient des crédits sur la journée de
solidarité pour compenser la dépendance
des personnes âgées et des personnes
handicapées
il y a une un détournement du fond de la
cns a donc c'est une légitime
reconnaissance par rapport à la
compensation de la dépendance des
personnes âgées de faire en sorte d'
adopter cet amendement qui ira
directement pour l'autonomie de nos
personnes âgées et non pas sur une loi
permet - témoin de vous dire au jour
d'aujourd'hui hypothétique nous
n'arrivons pas au jour d'aujourd'hui à
compenser cette dépendance à cause de la
pas comment demain envisager des mesures
nouvelles quand nous ne savons pas
aujourd'hui comment les financer un
gouvernement de gauche me semble-t-il
doit s'honorer d'assurer le financement
de ses prestations de social c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous demande de
supporter cet amendement présenté par
gérard roche
merci chers collègues je n'ai pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe udc udi us et sur
l'amendement 217 rectifier je vous
rappelle que l'avis de la commission est
défavorable l'avis du gouvernement est
défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées à l'article
56 du règlement ceux qui souhaitent
voter pour remettront secrétaire un
bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre métro
un bulletin bleu ce qui soit s'abstenir
métro un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos j'invite mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
résultat du scrutin numéro 26 sur
l'amendement numéro 217 rectifié
l'article 16 du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2013 nombre de votants 346 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 345 majorité absolue
des suffrages exprimés 173 pour
l'adoption 187 contre 158 le sénat a
adopté et donc l'amendement 389 tombe
nous allons voter sur l'article 6
explications de vote seize pardon
article 16 explications de vote mal à
masquer
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous avez affirmé à l'assemblée
nationale que cet article je vous cite
introduisez un nouveau droit celui de
l'accompagnement de la perte d'autonomie
mais en fait ce n'est pas le cas pour
l'heure l'article 16 se borne à
l'instauration d'une taxe c'est à dire
d'une mesure fiscale contraire au
principe de solidarité qui constitue la
solide et la sécurité sociale en tout
cas tel que avaient été définis par le
conseil national de la résistance
sans doute aurons-nous à discuter
prochainement du contenu de ce nouveau
droit et nous redoutons que la
discussion ne soit alors très contrainte
comme vous avez fait le choix de
déterminer le montant et l'assiette de
la taxe avant d'étudier les besoins vous
n'aurez que deux options soit adapté le
droit nouveau que vous avez mentionné
aux ressources dont vous disposez grâce
à cette taxe soit à partir des besoins
mais augmenter le rendement de la taxe
quoi qu'il en soit avec ce système
d'inspiration assurantiel et retraités
sont perdants qui plus est toujours
l'assemblée nationale vous avez ajouté
madame la ministre
c'est dans cette perspective que nous
constituons et c'est pourquoi nous
introduisons cette contribution des
retraités modique qui permet de marquer
que le financement de la perte
d'autonomie est un enjeu national
en somme parce que cette question est un
enjeu national
son financement ne devrait reposer que
sur une faible partie de nos concitoyens
l'argument par ailleurs parfaitement
repris par la droite qui n'a en la
matière aucune leçon à donner
je voudrais pour illustrer mes propos
prend un exemple le besoin en aide
humaine des personnes retraitées en
situation de perte ou d'absences
d'autonomie en raison de la survenue
pendant leur période d'activité d'un
accident d'une maladie professionnelle
est bien légitime que d'exiger de ces
derniers qu'ils contribuent eux-mêmes au
financement de leurs dépenses
d'autonomie ou bien faut-il que les
employeurs soient responsabilisés et
soumis à contribution
en outre pendant des années lorsqu'il
était salarié les personnes devenues
depuis retraités touchés par cette taxe
ont cotisé bien plus d'ailleurs que les
actionnaires qui s'enrichissaient du
fruit de leurs efforts est ce bien
normal de les taxer une seconde une
seconde fois
nous ne croyons pas et continuons à
penser qu'il faut résolument s'attaquer
à la spéculation et mettre le capital à
contribution vu que ce sont des saints
qui échappe aux salaires et donc aux
cotisations
dans son avis rendu en 2011 le conseil
économique social et environnemental
notez que pour la période 2006 2009 si
le résultat après impôts de nos sociétés
non financières se trouvent avec 37 5 %
de l'excédent brut d'exploitation le bo
en 2009 sensiblement dans la moyenne des
autres pays européens
les dividendes et autres revenus
distribués 24 7 ans en 2009 sont parmi
les plus élevés de l'union européenne
l'autofinancement disponible pour les
investissements en est réduit d'autant
et se situe avec 12e 8 % de le b
2009 parmi les plus bas d'europe il y a
donc bien comme nous ne cessons de le
répéter un coût du capital lequel nuit à
l'investissement et au financement de la
sécurité sociale
le rapport démontre également que cette
pratique est d'autant plus importante
que la part de valeur ajoutée qui est
créé haute je cite une nouvelle fois de
fait seuls 16 % des pme distribuent des
dividendes
cette proportion est trois fois plus
importante pour les grandes entreprises
celles dont la valeur ajoutée est la
plus élevée verse le plus de dividendes
cela justifie pleinement l'amendement
que nous avions déposé relatif à
l'instauration d'une modulation de
cotisations sociales en fonction de la
politique salariale des entreprises
tout cela nous conduit à constater que
malheureusement nos amendements sont
rejetés par le sénat et il était
crédible et pouvait générer des
ressources permettant au gouvernement de
renoncer à cet article mais vous ne
l'avez pas fait mais plus globalement je
voudrais dire que nous avons bien
conscience qu'il y a un besoin d'une
réflexion mais globale sur le
financement de l'assurance sociale et
plus particulièrement le financement de
la perte d'autonomie
mais cela ne doit pas se faire au détour
d'un article qui taxe les pensions de
retraite ça doit se faire dans une
réflexion beaucoup plus large
aussi et pour finir je vous le dis je
voudrais simplement dire pour finir que
cet article est d'une disposition
majeure de ce plfss
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
nous vendons un vote par scrutin public
si je n'ai je n'ai pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote
on n'a pas reçu le national a pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
j'ai donc été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe communiste
sur l'article 16
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement ceux qui souhaitent
voter pour remettront secrétaire un
bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre mais
trois bulletins bleus ceux qui
souhaitent s'abstenir remettra un
bulletin rouge le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos j'invite mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
je
résultat du scrutin numéro 27 sur
l'article 16 du projet de loi
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2013 nombre de votants 344 nombre de
suffrages exprimés
174 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés 88 pour l'adoption 154 contre
20 le sénat a adopté
nous en arrivons à l'article 17 et j'ai
une demande de parole de madame cohen la
question de l'élu local est une question
récurrente
elle en devient même une arlésienne si
je puis dire l'article 17 de ce plfss y
contribuer d'une certaine manière en
proposant d'affiliés les élus locaux au
régime général de la sécurité sociale
cette proposition aurait pour effet de
revenir sur l'état actuel du droit qui
considèrent exception faite des
indemnités de fonction que les
indemnités versées aux élus locaux ne
constituent pas des salaires et ne
peuvent donc pas être soumis à
cotisations et pour cause les élus
locaux ne sont pas contrairement aux
salariés placés dans une situation de
subordination en ce sens où on ne peut
pas parler d'emploi mais plutôt d'une
responsabilité d'une charge considéré
que ces indemnités sont des
rémunérations et donc qu'elle devrait
être soumise à cotisations et par voie
de conséquence ouvrir des droits sociaux
participent d'une professionnalisation
de la vie politique à laquelle nous
sommes pour notre part opposée je sais
beaucoup d'autres élus également la
volonté dessinatrice et des sénateurs du
groupe crc permettent à celles et ceux
de nos concitoyens qui voudraient
assumer des responsabilités locales de
pouvoir le faire dans un cas de leur
garantissant sécurité matérielle et
professionnelle une formation une
clarification du statut juridique et des
responsabilités de l'élu local
voilà les conditions indispensables pour
construire un tissu élective diversifié
actif
il faut donc travailler à l'élaboration
d'un véritable statut de l'élu local
qui mériterait pour le moins que nous
ayons un débat de portée générale sur ce
statut d'ailleurs ce thème est revenu
très fortement ici même au sénat lors
des états des états généraux de la
démocratie territoriale
il faut donc renforcer les dix polices
les dispositifs légaux censée protéger
les élus qui demeurent ou voudraient
demeurer salariés du secteur privé
le débat est moins par exemple de
trouver le moyen fidh de financer un
éventuel accès aux allocations chômage
en cas de fin de mandat que de faire en
sorte que le droit à la réintégration
soit pleinement opérationnel et qu'il se
fasse dans des conditions garantissant
le respect du droit à la promotion
le débat n'est pas tant d'autoriser le
versement de prestations familiales que
de faire en sorte que tous les élus
puissent disposer pendant le temps
qu'ils consacrent à leur mandat d'une
prise en charge intégrale peut-être par
la collectivité avec l'instauration de
fonds de péréquation des frais qu'elle
est il aurait engagé pour faire par
exemple garder leurs enfants
il faudrait également que les mandats
électifs locaux puis sur l'objet d'une
véritable validation des acquis ces
évolutions sont impératives et elles ne
doivent pas donner l'impression que les
élus bénéficient de dispositifs
dérogatoires au droit commun est en
quelque sorte extraordinaire par rapport
aux droits reconnus pour les salariés
cet argument valant naturellement pour
les parlementaires nationaux et
européens dont il faudra bien un jour
que l'on débatte ensemble or cet article
organise une affiliation systématique
des élus quelle que soit la couverture
des listes dont il bénéficie déjà par
ailleurs il pourrait donc cotiser deux
fois et par voie de conséquence
bénéficier de double droit cela pourrait
avoir pour effet immédiat de permettre
aux élus locaux de valider chaque année
4 trimestres d'assurance vieillesse
une telle mesure alors que nos
concitoyens subissent les contrecoups
d'une contre réforme des retraites
ready réduisant leurs droits et
prolongeant la durée légale de
cotisation ne nous paraît pas adapté et
mérite pour le moins une concertation de
plus grande ampleur par exemple avec
l'ensemble des associations des élus
en tout cas c'est ce que nous vous
proposons c'est pourquoi le groupe crc
s'abstiendra sur cet article
merci chers collègues nous en arrivons à
l'amendement de rectifier qui est
présentée par monsieur rapporteur
général au nom de la commission des
affaires sociales merci monsieur le
président madame la minime et la
ministre hui mes chers collègues
donc cet amendement vise à prévoir le
cas où des élus locaux auraient des
indemnités de fonction inférieur à 1500
16 euros par mois mais ne serait pas
couvert par ailleurs par un régime
obligatoire de sécurité sociale
il s'agit donc tout simplement par
instamment de leur permettre de cotiser
afin de s'ouvrir des droits à
prestations sociales à une couverture
maladie et à pension
merci monsieur l'important générale
madame la ministre l'avis du
gouvernement oui merci monsieur le
président le gouvernement donne un avis
favorable à cet amendement
les situations visé par votre amendement
monsieur le rapporteur général devrait
être exceptionnelle elle concerne des
élus dont les indemnités sont
actuellement assujetties aux cotisations
sociales qui ne le serait plus après la
réforme occasionnant ainsi une perte de
droits a priori seraient concernés les
adjoints des 230 commune entre 20000 et
50000 habitants ayant cessé toute
activité professionnelle pour exercer un
mandat à indemniser à moins de 1500 16
euros par mois et ne relevant pas d'un
régime obligatoire de sécurité sociale
ce sont donc des situations très
minoritaire marginal pour autant elle
existe et il paraît judicieux de prévoir
une continuité des règles pour ces
personnes avis favorable merci madame la
ministre nous votons sur ceux de
rectifier h des explications de vote
oui monsieur savary et je pense que les
arguments de professionnalisation les
mandats d'élu est tout à fait recevable
ce sont des cotisations accidents du
travail maladies professionnelles alors
que les élus exercent des fonctions dans
le cadre de l'heure
mandat électif je pense que c'est encore
une charge supplémentaire vis-à-vis des
collectivités locales que soit le
conseil généraux les conseils régionaux
qui vont encore avoir à porter sur leurs
budgets des contributions
supplémentaires comme s'ils n'en avaient
pas encore assez alors ça a cumulé à
l'augmentation du taux de cns cnr à
celle qui va encore amputée largement
les budgets de fonctionnement alors que
l'on nous dit attention au
fonctionnement si vous voulez derrière
investir et créer de la croissance
les journées l'éducation de nos enfants
passer à quatre jours et demi qui vont
alourdir à la fois pour les conseils
généraux les transports scolaires
ça a été chiffré par l'adf à 6%
supplémentaires où chaque département ce
qui concerne par exemple un département
moyens le département de la marne c'est
entre 500 nil et un million d'euros
supplémentaire alourdir les charges des
des villes des grandes villes touchées
par le dispositif puisque ça s'exerce
sur les élus qui ont une indemnité c'est
une indemnité d'ailleurs on dit bien une
indemnité supérieure à 1500 euros qui
vont être encore davantage touchés par
ce dispositif
l'augmentation du nombre de
bénéficiaires du rsa 1% par mois je les
d'hier en ce qui concerne mon
département tout cela sont des charges
qui deviennent terrible pour les
départements et donc derrière pour les
contribuables c'est la raison pour
laquelle je suis à titre personnel mais
sûrement avec d'autres pas enclins à
voter ce type de mesures merci chers
collègues je n'ai pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote monsieur plancade
merci monsieur le président le r d sur
vote aura en tout cas sa majorité cet
amendement parce que si par malheur les
propositions du rapport jospin vaut d
être voté pour ce pays on pense qu'il
aurait pu encore gardé quelques grains
pour ces élus qui se dévouent sans
compter pour nos communes
merci chers collègues je me cieux le
rapporteur général
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
mais chacun je vais simplement précisé
que l'amendement que j'ai proposé en
fait maintient la situation existante
pour à un nombre d'élus certainement
faible à la ministre vous l'avez
souligné
ménard mois pour que ses élus ne se
trouve pas dans une situation de vide
vis-à-vis de leur protection sociale
merci le seul à votre général je n'ai
plus de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement va bien levé la main merci
que ceux qui sont contre eux veulent
bien levé la main merci abstentions il
est adopté
nous votons sur l'article 17
explications de vote monsieur milon
merci monsieur le président madame à
ministre mes chers collègues
même si notre collègue rené paul savary
à poser les bonnes questions sur la
charge financière des collectivités
territoriales avec la mise en place des
dispositions de cet article 17
le groupe ump dans une partie de sa majo
dans sa majorité pardon a toujours
défendu la mise en place d'un statut de
l'élu
le sénat a d'ores et déjà travaillé sur
ce sujet je pense en particulier aux
rapports d'information de nos collègues
d'allier et péroné faciliter l'exercice
de mandats locaux réflexion autour du
statut de l'élu
nous avons adopté en juin 2011 la
proposition doit de nos collègues
bernard saugey marie hélène des esgaulx
qui vise à renforcer l'attractivité et à
faciliter l'exercice du mandat local
par ailleurs la france s'honore d'avoir
mis progressivement en oeuvre une série
de mesures favorisant l'engagement
citoyen si singulier qu'elle celui d'un
élu de la république la loi de 1992
relative aux conditions d'exercice des
mandats locaux
la loi de 2002 relative à la démocratie
de proximité
elles ont constitué des étapes
déterminantes et ont permis d'améliorer
sensiblement la situation des élus
locaux congé spécial crédit d'heures
formations allocation différentielle de
fin de mandat retraite
autant de dispositifs qui accompagne
désormais les élus avant pendant et
après l'exercice de leur mandat
toutefois il existe encore des freins à
l'engagement électoral surtout dans nos
petites communes
en effet la représentation politique
locale doit faire face à une crise de
l'engagement qui connaît un degré de
gravité sans précédent et qui risque de
provoquer une réelle crise des vocations
car l'exercice du mandat et vous le
savez mes chers collègues va bien au
delà des tâches de représentation
d'administration ou de gestion la
société se montre de plus en plus
exigeante vis-à-vis d'un représentation
démocratique pour laquelle la tradition
française impose une logique de
bénévolat il existe pourtant un statut
de l'élu consacré dans un chapitre du
code général des collectivités
territoriales
mais il est vrai même nous nous le
connaissons mal c'est pourquoi il est
nécessaire d'approfondir notre réflexion
sur cette question essentielle pour
l'avenir de l'engagement des élus locaux
et une grande partie du groupe ump votre
à cet article 17
merci chers collègues je n'ai pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
article 17 vais bien levé la main merci
que ceux qui sont contre veut bien levé
la main merci que ceux qui s'abstiennent
veuille bien levé la main il est adopté
nous en arrivons à l'article 18 je n'ai
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter
l'article 18 veulent bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veut bien
levé la main que ceux qui s'abstiennent
veuille bien levé la main il est adopté
nous arrivons à l'article 19 et à
l'amendement 135i présentée par monsieur
melon c'est amanda commandement de
suppression d'articles monsieur le
président le présent article vise en
effet à relever le plafond du taux de
contribution tarifaire d'acheminement
portant sur la distribution de gaz afin
de couvrir les besoins de financement du
régime spécial des retraites des
industries électriques et gazières
nous considérons qu'il n'est pas
équitable de faire reposer le
financement d'un régime spécial de
retraite
sur l'ensemble des consommateurs y
compris les plus modestes
en effet la contribution tarifaire
d'acheminement le ct 1 qui finance en
partie le déficit des régimes de
retraite des agents d'edf et gdf est à
la charge de tous les clients du gaz et
de l'électricité c'est à dire quasiment
je dis bien quasiment tous les français
seuls les bénéficiaires de ce régime
spécial ne seront pas touchés par la
hausse de la cité à puisque la facture
d'électricité d'un agent edf aussi entre
5 et 10% de celui d'un consommateur
particulier l'augmentation donc de s
était à vannes encadrent à répercuter
sur les consommateurs qui assisteront à
une hausse prévisible des tarifs il nous
souhaitons donc la suppression de cet
article
merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur général quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur le président 1,1 à
mme la ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement tend à supprimer donc
l'article 19 qui vise à relever la
fourchette des taux de la contribution
tarifaire d'acheminement donc la cpa
applicables à la distribution du gaz
je voudrais d'abord rappeler que la cda
a été créée par la loi du 9 août 2004
2004 notamment pour adapter le
financement du régime spécial de
retraite industries électriques et
gazières ieg g à l'ouverture du marché
de l'énergie à la concurrence
deuxième point cette loi prévoit que les
taux de la cité à sont fixés je cite en
fonction des besoins prévisionnels des
cinq prochaines années
en 2010 le précédent gouvernement a
décidé de maintenir inchangés les
niveaux de ses taux or depuis l'exercice
2011 la branche vieillesse des
industries électriques et gazières se
trouve de nouveau en déficit
le produit de ces analyses ne lui
permettant pas d'assurer l'intégralité
du financement des charges qui lui
incombent les re relèvement des taux de
ces terrasses implose donc ils
permettront de réduire le déficit d ing
de plus de 160 millions d'euros l'année
prochaine
troisième point que je voulais mettre en
avant les conséquences pour le
consommateur
elles seront mineurs selon l'étude
d'impact le surcoût sera de 27 centimes
par mois soit un peu plus de 3 euros par
an pour un foyer de cinq personnes
habitant un logement de 120 mètres
carrés équipée à l'électricité ces
différents éléments ont amené la
commission des affaires sociales à
émettre un avis défavorable à
l'amendement donc numéro 135 e monsieur
me l'on vient de présenter sur la
torture générale madame la ministre
quel est l'avis du gouvernement sur le
président l'avis du gouvernement est
défavorable
monsieur milon renoncer à l'augmentation
de là c'était à placerait le régime
spécial en déficit ce qui aboutirait à
fragiliser ceux qui en bénéficient et
les entreprises de la branche et je ne
reviens pas sur ce qu a excellemment dit
monsieur le rapporteur général sur le
faible impact de cette mesure sur les
consommateurs je voudrais simplement
vous rappeler deux ou trois points le
premier c'est que comme cela a été dit
ce système a été instauré en 2004 par le
ministre de l'époque de ministre d'état
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de l'industrie qui s'appelait nicolas
sarkozy s'est donc votre majorité qui a
instauré le principe d'une prise en
charge par les consommateurs de gaz et
d'électricité du financement d'une
partie des dépenses de retraite de ces
régimes monsieur milon je vois que vous
soyez je comprends que ça puisse
déplaire à certains de sur les bancs de
l'opposition mais c'est une réalité
alors faut-il dès lors que matt nous
nous avons rappelé qui a été le principe
de cette contribution et comment elle a
été déterminé pourquoi faut-il
aujourd'hui relever cette contribution
sur le gaz et l'électricité je crains
que là encore la majorité que vous avez
soutenu ne soit directement impliqué
puisque c'est le gouvernement précédent
qu'elle et ses dérivés la situation
financière de ce régime puisque
contrairement à ce qu'il prétendait les
retraites ne sont pas à financer 50
millions de déficit en 2011 pour la
section s'était à 130 millions de
déficit en 2012
180 millions de déficit en 2013 si nous
ne faisons rien d'où la question
suivante qui vient immédiatement à
l'esprit faut-il laisser continuer ce
déficit à se creuser ou assumer nos
responsabilités et bien le gouvernement
lui a choisi d'assumer ses
responsabilités plutôt que de voir
demain ce régime de retraite se
retrouver en cessation de paiement mais
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
prenons cette décision nous présentons
cet article qui permettra d'assurer que
les retraites des électriciens et des
gaziers pourront être payés
en 2013 c'est la raison pour laquelle
monsieur le sénateur milon j'apporte un
avis défavorable à votre amendement
merci madame la ministre
alors pour explication de vote monsieur
milon merci monsieur président juste
deux ou trois petites choses
vous avez bien compris dans l'exposé des
motifs qu'en fait je n'attaquais pas
obligatoirement l'augmentation de 7 et 1
mais je disais bien dans l'exposé des
motifs que cette augmentation d'hasselt
et à aller vers le consommateur mais
n'avait toujours pas vers les agents
d'edf nogent jet de gdf ni mène vers un
retraité d'edf ou de gdf qui eux avaient
des tarifs préférentiels
alors que monsieur sarkozy et ni cette
chose en place selon vous ça doit être
normal dans la mesure où elle n'est pas
égalitaire mais que vous qui parlez
toujours d'égalité pourquoi cette
fois-ci vous le mettez en place
vous êtes en train de suivre la même
méthode que président de la république
précédents
merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur marriner pour
explication de vote
adam le ministre mes chers collègues
j'avoue que je n'ai pas compris la
défense que vous avez fait de votre
dispositif en utilisant uniquement un
argument de politique politicienne
alors bien entendu à 6 mois de votre
installation
vous pouvez encore et j'allais dire
profitez en vous permettre ce type
d'arguments il me semble qu'au fur et à
mesure du temps qui va passer du temps
qui va passer avec les incohérences qui
sont celles de votre action vous pourrez
de moins en moins utilisé ce type
d'arguments en tout cas ce type
d'argument n'est pas une exonération de
tout et il me semble que notre groupe
est dans son rôle quand il pose le
problème quand il pose la question de la
répartition de cette mesure bien souvent
vous nous fait la morale en nous
expliquant
qu avec vous la répartition des efforts
et plus équitable alors ici nous
pointons et vous devriez avoir
l'honnêteté intellectuelle de le
reconnaître nous pointons une situation
particulière où certes il faut demander
un effort mais peut-être faut-il trouver
une autre formule que de répercuter sur
des consommateurs qui assisteront à une
hausse
incompréhensible des tarifs il me semble
que vis-à-vis d'autres catégories
socioprofessionnelles que les agents
d'edf et gdf
vous êtes beaucoup plus sévère n'est ce
pas dans vos appréciations
alors c'est cette cette politique de
convenance que nous dénonçons et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous voterons
l'amendement de suppression
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur desessard pour explication de
vote
monsieur ils ont en réalité c'est pas ça
que vous dénoncez puisque c'est normal
que les cotisations soit payée par
l'entreprise se sont payés par
l'entreprise sont payés par les produits
de l'entreprise
donc là c'est normal que ce soit
justement sur le prix de l'électricité
qui est vendu donc ça vous ne remettez
pas en cause mais ce que vous remettez
en cause
visiblement c'est que les agents d'edf
eux paient que 10 % du prix de
l'électricité c'est ça mais c'est peu